hey Vsauce Michael here
if you core a spear that is remove a
cylinder from it you'll be left with a
shape called a napkin ring because well
it looks like a napkin ring it's a
bizarre shape because if two napkin
rings have the same height well they'll
have the same volume regardless of the
size of the spheres they came from this
means that if you cut equally tall
napkin rings from an orange and from the
earth well one could be held in your
hand the other would have the
circumference of our entire planet but
both would have the same volume
I mentioned this counterintuitive fact
while making a kendama with Adam Savage
check that video out if you haven't or
better yet just come see us we're
bringing brain candy live to 24 new
cities this fall it's gonna be busy but
right now we're talking about balls and
coring them I have here two napkin rings
from very differently sized spheres one
is from a tiny ball just a little tomato
that I've chord so it's got a little
hole in it right there the other napkin
ring is made from an orange but both
napkin rings have the same height the
tomato has a smaller circumference than
the orange which means less volume but
it's ring is thicker which means more
volume both of those effects exactly
cancel out so these two napkin rings
have identical volumes they take up the
same amount of space by the way orange
oil is flammable to see why the napkin
ring problem is true let's discuss
Cavalier ease principle it states that
for any two solids like these two
cylinders I've built here sandwiched
between parallel planes if any other
parallel plane intersects both in
regions of equal area no matter where
it's taken from well then the solids
have the same volume now that's clearly
true here these cylinders are built out
of stacks of vsauce stickers 100 in each
stack so their volumes are the same
if I skew one of them like this its
shape will change but it's volume hasn't
it still contains the same amount of
stuff I haven't added or subtracted
stickers and Cavalier ease principle
ensures that they still have the same
volume because any cross-section taken
from down here up here in the middle
anywhere
will always give us a region of the same
area as the other because those regions
are always equal area circles now let's
apply calgary's principle to napkin
rings we can see the two napkin rings
with similar Heights have identical
volumes by showing that when cut by a
plane the area of one's cross section
always equals the area of the others now
to do this notice that the area of the
spheres cross section minus the area of
the cylinders cross section gives us the
area of the napkin rings cross section
depending on where we slice the napkin
ring the cross sections will have
different areas but they will always be
the same as each other let's calculate
the areas of these blue rings first of
all let's call the height of the napkin
ring H and the radius of the sphere
they're cut from capital R all right
perfect now a cross section of a sphere
like this and a cross section of a
cylinder like this are both circles so
their areas can be determined by using
pi times the radius squared so if we
want to find the area of the spheres
cross section and subtract the area of
the cylinders cross section draw a
picture of a cylinder here all we need
to do is take pi multiply it by the
radius of the sphere cross section
square that and then subtract pi times
the radius of the cylinder squared but
what are their radii well if this is the
center of the sphere we can draw a line
straight up to the corner of the
cylinder down the side of the cylinder
and then connect to form a right
triangle the Pythagorean theorem will
really help us here it tells us that the
length of one side squared plus the
length of the other side squared equals
the length of the hypotenuse squared
this distance right here this side of
the triangle is what we want it's the
radius of the cylinder so we'll call
this the little R radius of the cylinder
beautiful little picture there so the
radius of the cylinder squared plus this
side length which is just half the
height of the cylinder so the height of
the cylinder divided by 2 squared equals
the hypotenuse squared
the hypotenuse happens to be the radius
of the sphere itself which is capital R
perfect now let's solve for the radius
of the cylinder which is what we want
we'll just subtract H over 2 squared
from both sides that'll give us the
radius of the cylinder squared equaling
the radius of the sphere squared minus
1/2 the height of the cylinder squared
we can take the square root of both
sides so that we wind up with the radius
of the cylinder equaling the square root
of the radius of the sphere minus 1/2
the height of the cylinder squared
perfect ok now let's take a look at the
area of a cross-section of the sphere
now for this let's draw a straight line
from the center out to the edge of the
spheres cross-section and then we'll go
straight down and connect back up a look
another right triangle let's call this
height Y and notice that this distance
now the side of the triangle down here
is actually the radius of the circle
cross section up here they're both equal
so we don't want to solve for this the
radius of the circle that is the spheres
cross section okay so we know that the
radius of the spheres cross section
squared plus this distance squared which
is y equals the hypotenuse squared well
what do you know the hypotenuse is the
radius of the sphere again capital R
okay let's subtract Y squared from both
sides the radius of the spheres cross
section squared equals the radius of the
sphere squared
- y-squared we'll take the square root
of both sides and end up learning that
the radius of the spheres cross-section
equals the square root of the radius of
the sphere squared - y squared y is the
height that this cross-section is taken
from above the equator the higher up we
take these cross sections of the sphere
the smaller their radii will be whereas
the cylinders radius is always the same
no matter where we cut from Oh anyway
let's take these two radii and plug them
into our formula
okay the area of the cross section of
the sphere is what we want first okay
that's just the square root of R squared
- y squared not too bad now the radius
of the cylinder is the square root of R
squared minus 1/2 the height of the
cylinder squared now what you might
notice is that we're taking the square
root of something and then squaring it
so these actually cancel each other out
perfect much more simple looking but now
let's distribute PI to the terms inside
the parentheses so PI times R squared
gives us PI R squared pi times negative
Y squared gives us negative PI y squared
then a negative pi times R squared is
negative PI R squared negative pi times
negative H over 2 squared is positive PI
H over 2 squared great now we can keep
simplifying but what you might notice is
that we have a PI R squared and a minus
PI R squared let it equal 0 so these
completely cancel each other out
but what we're left with are terms
containing no mention of the spheres
radius whether the radius is large or
small doesn't matter all you need to
know to find the area of the cross
section of a napkin ring is the height
of the napkin ring why of course is
bounded by the height of the napkin ring
these blue areas have the same area as
each other and this will be true no
matter where we cut the cross section
across the napkin ring meaning by
cavalier YZ principle that both napkin
rings have the same volume
yay with teeth
but what does this mean for you for life
in the universe well as we know if you
like it you should put a ring on it but
if you like it don't know it's finger
width and only want to offer it a
predetermined amount of material you
should put a napkin ring on it and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
on August 21st 2017 there will be a
total solar eclipse the shadow of the
moon will race across the contiguous
United States it's going to be
incredible and a little bit scary I'm
sure I will be viewing it from organ
with my friends at Atlas obscura
I can't wait but keep your eyes safe if
you want to view the Eclipse you have to
have special eye protection the
Curiosity box comes with such glasses
these block 99.999% of visible light
that's what it takes to be able to look
right at the Sun that's actually what I
love about these glasses if there's no
Eclipse going on you can still just look
at the Sun notice that it's a ball maybe
imagine what kind of napkin ring you'd
like to make it into the current
curiosity box is my favorite the one
that you'll get it you subscribe right
now comes with all kinds of cool stuff
that comes with a poster showing that
all the planets and Pluto can fit
between the earth and the moon
it also comes with science gadgets like
these levitating magnetic rings pretty
cool also a portion of all proceeds go
to Alzheimer's research so it's good for
your brain and everyone else's brain
check it out I hope to see you at brain
candy live and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]